Kamala Harris accused of lying about
Florida's new black history curriculum
the vice president traveling to
Jacksonville and Blasting the State's
new board of education standards on
teaching slavery
they want to replace history with lies
middle school students in Florida to be
told that enslaved people benefited from
slavery they insult Us in an attempt to
Gaslight us and we will not have it
instead they dare to push propaganda to
our children
this is the United States of America
we're not supposed to do that the media
piling on over the vice president's
concerns
free housing permanent employment and
all you can eat cornbread
Board of Education in Florida wants you
to see that job description and think
you know maybe slavery wasn't so bad but
this is the game that they have been
playing trying to both sides racism and
white supremacy you might have to laugh
it's so disgusting that there were
personal benefits of any kind uh to
slaves and just because black people
write it don't mean that it doesn't mean
it's got to be accurate shame on you
people in Florida how dare you try to
whitewash slavery he felt a lot of
people around this country are starting
to feel that we can't teach the correct
history of this country because it makes
white kids uncomfortable so you get the
idea but National Review says Kamala
Harris has brazenly lying about the
curriculum Harris is singling out only
one bullet in the program that says this
slaves develop skills which in some
instances could be applied for their
personal benefit National Review points
out that there are 190 other passages
Harris is not mentioning that teach
about the evils and horrors of slavery
and two African-American Scholars who
actually created the new curriculum they
are defending it claiming it's being
taken out of context with one calling
Kamala Harris's claims quote
categorically false he says the vice
president is misinterpreting with a
controversial passage means
it is the case that Africa's prove
resourceful resilient and adaptive and
were able to develop skills and
aptitudes which serve to their benefit
both while enslaved and after
enslavement this is hot on the campaign
Trail Rhonda Santos was asked about this
in Utah here's what he said
absolutely ridiculous it's totally
outrageous you guys can look on the
website of the Florida Department of
Education you know they got a lot of
Scholars together to do a lot of
standards and a lot of different things
but these are the most robust standards
in African-American history probably
anywhere in the country she's going to
come down to the State of Florida and
try to chirp and try to try to demagogue
it got political real fast over the
weekend Greg and Charles Cook's piece in
National Review runs several Pages
because he lists all 190 of the other
passages that Kamala Harris didn't
mention it's weird it's like the media
wants you to believe The Osmond Brothers
came up with a curriculum that it was
all evil white people it's actually
that's why they keep saying Floridians
because then you don't know what race it
was again though I have to sound like a
broken record this is not a real story
at all this was completely made up it
was snippet journalism once again she
took one piece out of a huge thing and
turned it into some kind of screed
Against Racism and all this other stuff
it's not real she sounded drunk but I
often sound drunk at times you know what
I hate most about this that we all have
to do the work yes that Kamala was
supposed to do so she comes out there
she lies she did no preparation what
happens every fool like me this weekend
has to like read the curriculum I'm
exhausted I wanted to play I wanted to
hang out with my dog but it does gross
you out I think I get grossed out when I
see this because I imagine how much a
better country we'd be if people didn't
go on this this crazy fake where a word
divided country BS I think we need like
a colorblind summer you know how much
better everyone would feel if blacks
didn't feel oppressed because the media
told them to and that their their uh
co-workers and their classmates weren't
seen as oppressors because they happened
to be white that would be really nice
this was not the administration we were
promised right we were supposed to have
by old Joe everybody was supposed to get
along everybody now all it is is stuff
like this to create division right we
now have to be we have to feel guilty at
all times about who our ancestors were
and we're always going to be the target
always be the Target and that's
apparently keeps them out of trouble I
don't know
um there was also this idea that Kamala
Harris like one of the first things that
she did was figure out a way to oh okay
this is something that I can do where I
can get the Democrats perhaps into
interested in her her numbers with them
are even very low Jim Messina is a
former Obama guy he's a campaign guy
knows politics very well this is the
Democrat point of view on the politics
Sometimes the best gifts in politics are
ones that the other side gives you I
love how quickly she decided to go down
there the next day her remark she was
not scripted she looked at the at the
cameras and just said what was in her
heart and reminds you why he why she
first came to prominence so it's not
about the substance but about the
politics and maybe she does get a score
on that one Jesse I don't think she's
going to get a score at all because
everybody knows she's lying and I just
have to ask the African-Americans
watching right now what's it like to be
lied to by Kamala Harris what's it like
to be lied to by these buffoons on MSNBC
who didn't read the curriculum or the
view have no idea what the story is have
no idea what's going on down in Florida
and they act upset they act enraged
on your behalf
based on a lie I have the
African-American PhD we just heard from
Dr Allen is going to be on the show
tonight I mean he says this right here
this is well documented among historians
this is historical fact that slaves did
develop skills while they were enslaved
and then used those skills as
blacksmiths uh as in agriculture uh
tailoring uh in the shipping business to
then use to benefit themselves and their
families once they were freed that's not
controversial and it actually speaks to
the resilience and the aptitude of the
enslaved African Americans who were at
the time able to better themselves and
able to improve their situation despite
brutal
brutal conditions horrific and important
conditions the guy says this in the
statement after blasting Harris the
attempt to reduce slaves such as victims
of Oppression fails to recognize their
strength courage and resiliency during a
difficult time in American history
this is probably the most rigorous
African-American studies curriculum I
have ever seen I mean this goes back
pre-atlantic slave trade this goes to
the Quakers the abolitionists the cotton
gin post reconstruction all the way up
to the present
this should be taught in every single
middle school high school in the United
States this is the best of the best
created by African-American scholars in
the State of Florida and Kamala Harris
is either dumb and didn't read anything
about it or she knows the truth and is
decided to lie to the American people
about it I think it's disgusting and why
doesn't Kamala Harris want African
Americans and white Americans to know
that black Americans did learn skills
despite
being enslaved why doesn't she want them
to learn that Jessica do you think that
she read the whole thing and just
decided to cherry pick something I I do
think that she read the whole thing and
I think that it's an incredibly complex
piece when you look it's 191 passages
you have some good and and frankly I'm
just fundamentally uncomfortable with
the sentence that blacks benefited at
all from this and
uh you know it made me think of someone
obviously I'm not black but I'm Jewish
would someone say about the Holocaust
for instance that there were some
benefits for Jews right while they were
hanging out in concentration camps you
learned a strong work ethic right maybe
you learned a new skill did you ever
meet man search for meaning Vic Frankel
talks about how you had to survive in a
concentration camp by having skills you
had to be useful utility utility kept
you alive also talking about middle
schoolers here and there's a lot of
concern about what age people are
prepared to understand complex issues
I'm not sure that 12 is the right age to
start hearing things like and when you
were enslaved here in America
gender or ideology just let me finish
Rhonda santis knows that this is bad for
him because his first response was I
didn't do it I'm not involved in it we
do know that its response to his 2022
acts the code stop woke Act
and we also know that the type of people
are in charge of this overhaul maybe not
Dr Allen who you're going to have on
tonight or someone like Kim Daniels
who's on tape saying I thank God for
slavery because without it I would still
I would be an Africa worshiping a tree
she's also an anti-semite she threw in
that Jews own everything which is a
classic Trope but the Florida Department
of Education released a statement in
response to Kamala Harris's uh speech
saying you know she's got it totally off
base it includes I think 16 examples of
these slaves that learned their skills
while they were doing this and Joshua's
starting from Georgetown pointed out
that it's riddled with inaccuracy so
first of all they say James Forten as an
example he wasn't a slave he was a
sailor in the revolution then we've got
a couple of your blacksmiths by the way
who are not blacksmiths at all Ned Cobb
he was a sharecropper who became the
head of the Alabama Federation
sharecropper Union an amazing example of
achievement Lewis Latimer as well he was
called a blacksmith slave in the Florida
Department of Education piece but he was
an inventor who ended up getting two
patents and was hired by the Edison
Company
so when I asked him tonight ask him yeah
exactly that we'll find out exactly
we will it just felt that they were
trying really hard to de-emphasize that
the American experience with slavery was
so bad they talk about how much worse it
was in other places it was really bad
here it's like akin to when people say
oh like Sally Hemmings was Thomas
Jefferson's girlfriend
do you think it's bad to bring up the
fact that slavery exists right now no I
I'm not because that would actually make
us look good too
you see my point
let me ask Katie do you think how do you
think Rhonda Santos has handled this
um controversy well first I would say
that liberals apparently think that
teaching critical race Theory to
kindergartners is fine but teaching
middle school and high schoolers real
American history with this very thorough
curriculum they're not mentally or
emotionally prepared for it so I would
argue that this is a much better
curriculum than CRT
um I think that Jim Messina's words
about it being from the vice president's
heart and that's what really matters
rather than relying on the truth and
what is in the curriculum is very
telling in terms of how Ron DeSantis has
handled this I think that he's a little
bit distracted by his campaign and he
allows and delegates people inside his
government to and he trusts them to do
exactly this and that's why he hired a
descendant of slaves Dr William Allen to
write this curriculum to be involved and
to make sure that his voice was heard
when it came to what was being taught he
is not offended by the line about skills
that were obtained and then used later
when slaves were freed and he's a
descendant of slave Kamala Harris
they've been invited Administration has
been attacking Ron desanton since early
2020 because they've seen him as a
threat for 2024 but now Kamala Harris
needs something to do and so she
parachutes in to Florida and I doubt
that she read the 216-page curriculum
because she doesn't even read the briefs
that her staff gives her but she did use
a single sentence about skill
development took it completely out of
context doesn't understand the bigger
picture with the curriculum and then
starts pumping racial politics politics
which then Jim Messina said was he was
proud of doing that so that's on a Unity
message and so you know clearly they're
going after Florida in their typical
fashion but it's really sad that they're
doing it on a very out of context
position when they have been staying for
years they want African-American history
and slavery taught in schools as Jesse
said this is a comprehensive very
important curriculum and they're tearing
it down because it's not because they're
using it as a political opportunity
against their looking forward to Jesse's
interview tonight 8 PM Eastern hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else